maxime vous vous étiez souvent goûté à
une plus petite échelle évidemment
moquer rejeté tapé par des doutes et
pèse parfois beaucoup de pression
psychologique aussi mais je ne me suis
jamais laissé faire et dans la mesure où
j'en ai tout de suite et toujours parler
à mes parents à la direction y ait des
sanctions qui ont été faites allègrement
et aujourd'hui quand on sait que un
jeune sur dix est concerné par le
harcèlement scolaire c'est donc ces sept
cent mille sept cent mille enfants
il faut réagir il faut en parler
aujourd'hui à l'époque et pas forcément
un numéro au jury un numéro numéro c'est
le tremplin vous avez 31 c'est gratuit
voyez vous pouvez dire et vous libérer
de la parole alors qu'ils tuent des
moments difficiles école avant qu on
s'intéresse à noter - ce soir oui
mathieu non mais évidemment mais ce qui
est vraiment j'étais en pension deux ans
ça fait rire comme ça mais c'est sûr que
y'a rien de plus méchant qu'un enfant on
était en pension il y avait des garçons
à côté les filles de l'autre une
conduite d'un garçon entre guillemets un
peu différent et que vous commencez à le
comprendre ce que vivent certainement ce
garçon vous mettez pas vraiment des mots
dessus vous sentez que les choses
différentes en vous mais vous êtes seul
l'assuré quand vous êtes seul comme ça
et que autour il ya que des garçons et
que malheureusement vous faites l'erreur
comme j peut-être pu le faire aussi
certainement lui aussi d'en parler un
petit peu de second fier et ben vous
devenez évidemment la risée vous devenez
le celui qui se fait insulter celui
qu'on met de côté celui qui est pas
vraiment un garçon mais moi j'ai pas été
harcelés dieu merci mais j'ai un
souvenir de la pension horrible que j'ai
vécue comme une prison où mon père
m'avait mis là parce que j'avais perdu
ma mère bref il fallait vous mettre
quelque part c'était horrible parce que
j'étais un peu gringalet pas très fort
et malheureusement certainement un peu à
peu sensible et c'est de commencer à se
voir j'avais 16 ans et cd souvenir
horrible
or ici comme si c'est ce qui vous a
peut-être fait choisir de d'être dans la
lumière d'être ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui
peut-être oui peut-être certainement en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que ça m'a
au début aujourd'hui je n'ai pas fait
mais après il ya un espèce de sentiment
en tout cas de vengeance alors prêtre
vous êtes se montrer c'est de dire je
vais réussir quand même parce que
l'humiliation les traits psychologiques
jamais été frappé mais par exemple c'est
un truc tout bête c'était à l'époque et
d'une cabine téléphonique on avait une
carte prépayée la carte et on zappe nos
parents le week-end et moi je faisais la
queue comme ça on attendait dans la
cabine avec sa carte prépayée et au
moment où c'était à moi y avait deux
garçons un peu costaud qui arrivait et
avec d'ailleurs la bêtise que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure ce que c'était pour rire
mais du coup j'ai repensé maintenant moi
je peux le dire mais envoûtant traitant
de tous les noms [ __ ] paix des
machins toile interview tu dégages
il prenait sa carte il se dégageait il y
en a un qui vous tenait comme ça par
deux
et qu'ils attendaient bon voila c'était
ces choses là où vous appelez au féminin
tout le temps en femme tout le temps
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est
supportable touche évidemment ce jeune
garçon il n'y a pas que sur la sexualité
mais ce sont des choses horribles et
malheureusement ce qui est compliqué
c'est là où il faut que les professeurs
interviennent c'est qu'on ne changera
pas l'enfant l'enfant par nature est
cruel ils tuent les animaux et machin
c'est souvent comme ça les enfants par
net alors